bien il est 10 heures 12 et je commence
à tourner la vidéo qui sort aux parce
que je me suis pas réveillée comme un
réveil c'est marqué dessus salut la team
ortalo j'ai remarqué que dans les
commentaires vous me demandiez souvent
comment vous pouviez faire pour vous
entraîner à la détection de signaux non
verbaux fait bien l'objet de cette vidéo
dit dimanche
et concernant le concours de vendredi je
fais le tirage au sort là dans quelques
minutes et je mettrai le nom des
gagnants parce que le faire gagner
plusieurs personnes dans la description
alors j'ai bien réfléchi et je trouve ça
hyper légitime de me demander comment
vous pouviez vous entraîner alors
évidemment on vous pouvez observer les
gens en permanence mais c'est compliqué
pour les premières phases
d'apprentissage et c'est vrai que j'ai
un petit peu oublié ça puisque j'ai
passé ce cap la solution c'était de
créer un jeu vous allez proposer un jeu
à faire à vos amis et votre famille peu
importe même aujourd'hui et sous
prétexte de ce jeu qui n'est pas un
prétexte pour les bleus fait mais pour
vous entraînez vous allez pouvoir
peut-être les bluffer mais assurément
pouvoir prendre le temps d'observer dans
une circonstance qui est plus naturelle
plus naturel que de regarder fixement
quelqu'un qui vous parle comme ça sans
aucune raison vous allez proposer à
quelqu'un le jeu de l'intrus c'est à
dire vous mettez une personne en face de
vous et vous lui demander de répondre à
des questions très simples comme quel
est ton âge quel est ton prénom et
ensuite deux à trois questions pour
stimuler sa recherche visuelle ou
auditive
si tu as déjà eu un animal qu'elle était
la couleur de cet animal est ce que tu
peux me fredonner ta musique préférée
des cris mois les vêtements que tu avais
hier attention à cette question qui peut
faire très perverse aussi et vous allez
voir forcément tous ces mouvements
oculaires je vous invite d'ailleurs à
regarder les vidéos que j'avais faite
sur la détection de mensonges sur la pnl
je vous mets tout ça dans la description
si les liens directs ce sera plus rapide
vous allez en tout cas pouvoir voir
comment fonctionnent ces yeux et vous de
lui proposer un autre jeu directement
après c'est de vous raconter deux choses
qui sont vraies et une chose qui est
fausse de petites histoires très courte
qui lui sont vraiment véritablement
arrivé et une autre phrase qui est
inventé ou qui ne lui appartient pas
mais qui revendique et c'est beaucoup
mieux
il décide dans quel ordre ils voulaient
raconte et à la fin vous serez capable
de dire qu'elle est très la phrase un
truc parce que forcément vous allez
regarder tous les signes du mensonge
qu'on a pu voir dans les vidéos et en
plus de ça vous avez assez peu de chance
de vous raté puisque vous allez aussi
vous concentrer sur les mouvements
oculaires et vous allez voir que quand
il va rencontrer son mensonge
les yeux bougeront quasi pas le plus qui
bougeront ce sera vers le côté créatif
et ils ne bougeront quasiment pas
puisqu'il n'ya pas de recherche mémorial
à faire et c'est très très flagrant et
comme c'est un signe qui est très facile
à repérer dans ce jeu vous avez tout le
temps en même temps de vous concentrer
sur tous les autres conseils que je
donne et dans les vidéos pour regarder
de quelle manière il apparaît sur la
personne
petit bonus et ça c'est un plus en fait
petit bonus qui va bien vous pouvez lui
demander de faire la même chose les yeux
fermer les paupières fermées parce qu'on
voit beaucoup mieux les mouvements
oculaires
quand les paupières sont closes ou
encore mieux les yeux bougent et là je
vous ai proposé que la personne elle
raconte deux histoires vraies une
histoire fausse mais ça peut être trois
histoires vraies une fausse cas
devraient une fausse voire même trois
vraies et deux fosses vous pouvez après
corser la difficulté pour mieux encore
vous entraîner l'intérêt en plus de cet
entraînement c'est vous pouvez le faire
avec toujours le même personne c'est pas
gênant du tout voilà c'est presque c'est
presque un tp aujourd'hui ses travaux
pratiques
mais j'espère que ça va répondre à une
question que vous m'avez beaucoup
beaucoup posé en parlant de beaucoup
beaucoup vous avez été plus de 2300 à
participer au concours vous l'avez
lancée vendredi
je fais le tirage au sort avec le site
la de trucs aléatoire que vous m'aviez
montré il ya des mois de ça et je mets
le résultat des gagnants directement
dans la description jeu j'avais dit que
je ferais gagner un livre et puis en
fait je vais en faire gagner plusieurs
donc si vous voyez votre nom en dessous
sachez que mardi je commanderai
directement les livres qui arriveront
directement chez vous merci d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo jusqu'au bout
j'espère que ça va vous servir et que ça
vous a plu et si c'est le cas
n'oubliez pas de faire un petit pouce en
l'air là c'est très important les pouces
en l'air parce que si vous en mettez
beaucoup sur cette vidéo je referai un
espèce de truc de travaux pratiques en
fait je me rends compte que ce que je
vous apprends vous arrivez pas toujours
à voir comment l'appliquer donc si ça
vous dit qu'on fasse d'autres dans le
même état d'esprit vous bombardez et est
un bruitage complètement en celle où
passait un excellent dimanche n'oubliez
pas de vous abonner à lâcher avant de
partir puisque le mental blog c'est une
vidéo par jour pendant un an
donc rendez vous demain à 17h mon pote
ciao